في مطابخ فنادق Paris's Palace ،
يتم صنع الفن كل يوم مرحبًا به
هنا ، حيث تم تحويل معجنات المطبخ
التي تم تحويلها بواسطة Instagram إلى رؤيتها وكذلك
طهاة المعجنات التي يتم تناولها الآن على الإنترنت
مثل Superstars مثل Nicola Garcio من
فندق utisia الذي يعمل بشق الأنفس
في رأس السنة الجديدة.  تصميم عشية
طموح بقدر ما سيكون سريع الزوال أحصل على
قلمي ثم أحاول الحصول على المعرف الرئيسي
أكثر أو أقل لمعرفة ما
سأفعله وكيف سأفعل ذلك
بالعمل مع السكر كما لو كنت ستعمل
مع الزجاج  بالضبط إذا كنت تسير على هذا المنوال ،
يمكنك أن تقطع نفسك
بهذا الشيء نفسه تمامًا
الذي ستراه يبدأ مثل
هذا مجرد سقي السكر ، إنه أمر
لا يصدق إنه مجرد شيء مثل
السائل جدًا ومن ثم سيكون
هشًا ويعمل مثل الزجاج 68  69 70.
كل شيء الآن سوف يبرد ،
يجب أن أذهب سريعًا في الواقع
لأنك ترى أنه بدأ بالفعل في الانكسار ، كما
ترى أنه من الصعب بالفعل هنا في
كل مرة أقوم بالسحب والطي ،
سيكون لديك بعض الهواء بين
وبسبب الهواء ، يمكنك الحصول على
شيء مثل ترك
لامعة ، حسنًا ،
تبرد بتلاتي الصغيرة
والنتيجة النهائية ، وردة أجمل
من الطبيعة
تقريبًا
لأن تغيير المعجنات هو نتيجة
لحقيقة أننا ننظر إليها على
Instagram ، نعم بالضبط  الآن بشكل أساسي
علينا أن نكون دقيقين للغاية
ونظيفين للغاية وأنيقين للغاية لأننا نريد أن يكون لدينا
شبكة اجتماعية غير Instagram تساعدنا حقًا على وضعنا
في الخطوة الأولى
لماذا تحصل على مجفف شعر أنا فضولي في
الواقع  سنستخدمها
كمروحة قوية لتبريد قطع السكر
الرائعة للتأكد من أنها تلتصق
ببعضها البعض بشكل صحيح
وإلا ستتحرك ببطء لأنها لا تزال
دافئة في
المنتصف بالطبع كلما ارتفعت
يصبح الأمر معقدًا تمامًا
هنا الخطر هنا ولكننا نحب المخاطرة ،
لذا
أعني أنني يجب أن ألتزم الصمت ربما قبل
الآن ، هل تصل إلى النهاية هذا
المنتج النهائي
تقريبًا قطعة من الذهب
عندما تفكر في  قبل ساعة ،
كان الماء والسكر شيئًا
سريعًا للغاية ، والآن أصبح صعبًا مثل الحجر
وهو مثل الوقوف تمامًا كما لو أنه رائع جدًا
عام جديد سعيد ،
وهو عمل فني يمكن الاستمتاع به في
حفلة ليلة رأس السنة بالفندق.
حتى أكثر من الحنك
وسيستمر ذلك لبضعة أيام فقط حتى عام
ميليسا بيلسيانين باريس